how insane though this is your stage
debut and you're like fully
naked i mean that's doubly scary it's
quite insane jessie williams bears it
all and we mean all on stage in the
broadway revival of take me out this has
got to be i would imagine the smartest
play that involves nudity and admits
that he doesn't love it when the
audience chimes in it's still terrifying
but uh once you do it
you know it's time it's a human body the
40 year old actor stopped by watch what
happens live with andy cohen on monday
with his co-star jesse tyler ferguson
and got candid about how the audience
responds when he strips down to his
birthday suit a non-reaction is a really
interesting reaction yeah yeah quiet
right yeah no right it creates a lot of
issues like a reaction do you like a
reaction i don't like any of it i don't
like any of it none of you can't i've
learned in my minutes in theater which
is all the first all at first for me is
don't start trying to read into it okay
because it just creates more insecurity
how how how insane though this is your
stage debut and you're like fully
naked i mean that's doubly scary told
it's quite insane but
it's so it's the first so i've you know
got nothing to compare it to and i'll be
pretty uh i won't be scared of anything
after this not only is it jesse's
broadway debut it's also patrick j adams
too i don't have anything to compare it
to this is the only way i've debuted but
um
it makes it wholly terrifying not just
partially
and yes patrick gets fully nude too you
know we're going uh yeah although
patrick adams
eti caught up with the cast back in
february leading up to the show's
opening and they kept it real about
taking it off there's something it's so
fully integrated into the play that you
know when i first heard about taking out
and i just really naked guys in a play
you sort of make assumptions that maybe
it's sort of gratuitous or not necessary
and with this play it is so fully
integrated into the fabric of really
what it's about and people being
stripped bare and getting down to the
base eggs going
somewhere fishy
uh and so it's it's kind of great in
that way that you feel like you're
servicing such a beautiful play you
should also just say this because i
don't want people to not buy tickets i'm
not nude
so
don't worry you don't have to see it
not something you have to worry about
you know you get the thermostat right
you get things settled
and the whole cast except for again not
me but the rest of the cast is also in
the same boat so it's not like just
you alone on stage as for jesse he's
also making waves for his highly
anticipated return to grey's anatomy for
the upcoming season 18 finale you'll
recall jesse exited the medical drama
last year after 12 seasons as dr jackson
avery i had your back
i know this is a surprise but i'm just
asking you to
do the same for me and while we await
seeing him at graceland memorial once
again the actor teased what fans can
expect when it comes to his character
and april played by sarah drew they are
right exist in some form or fashion you
will see them
on screen possibly on the same screen
and while jesse didn't reveal too much
e.t chatted with the cast last week and
they gave a little more insight into the
big j pro reunion i don't know what i
can say and what i can't say but i can
say this they will be really happy
they're back on the screens that's what
matters and to get jessie back and to
get sarah back
i mean they're a dynamic duo they are
both featured in this episode which is
kind of exciting because we got sarah
back and and jesse and we love them so
much and so having them here like i was
weepy even in the table reads listen in
the in the episode i think there's a lot
of things i'll be really excited about
and really happy about and then other
things that's a little shocking and like
make them cry it's a good mix
[Music]